this is Lars and the cool kids obviously
a player Lars and the real girl of which
this has nothing in common with no but
like I could actually see an episode
similar to that and Steve many a blooper
hurts like Tina I have a kool kids by
the way just look like alternative
versions of the gems I thought I got to
be like a twist like it's actually like
you know that I was some sorrow version
of the Seinfeld team from Seinfeld a wee
cricket when they find uh are you
finished yes I am sorry like when they
find the bizarro versions of them's
already how George oh yeah yeah are like
he races to reveal like no no this was
like we were testing you to see if you
would actually bring them up to the hill
or as if it's like no what
why would they look so much like them I
mean it's like the really pale one has
like the point where they're you know
the one that has the shades is sort of
the big lip and everything and like I
felt I guess the other one didn't look
too much like the moral lesson was
definitely important one don't try too
hard to be cool or you might be covered
in moss yeah
and maybe die as I want kids and a
rolling stone gathers no moss so try to
be a rolling stone that goes up a hill
to get the most bloom into flowers Jim
let's see beauty in all things a weird
show yeah um I feel like this episode
was fine I mean it's kind of it kind of
felt like an after-school special as
well like just don't give in to peer
pressure and stuff and I did laughs and
we got about three minutes and I'm like
I feel like it's after school again yeah
like we're just not yeah I returned
watching it we've been watching it when
we get around to these it's closer to
the afternoon so yeah I just feel it's
like about 2:00 2:30 3:00 o'clock right
now times like I feel like I'm a kid
again watching cartoons yeah like we
just got home from school or whatever
oh but yeah and then you have this
lesson about like don't give in to peer
pressure and everything we're just still
good lesson you know and they they do it
fine um just attractive anything like
especially stands out to me about I mean
I like the idea of getting the model
doctor I want to sit dog
Chapter three that sounds an amazing
it's just a dog flying a helicopter I
just I kept staring at it in the
background I'm like is the dog
helicopter just the dog fly a helicopter
is he like is it like your game posture
that I just I got add I just keep going
in my head over and over again how dogs
not have were dog Kelly this movie
actually damn now I really want to UM
somebody make talk actor uh uh and make
it so good that we need two more uh but
yeah it's uh I like how the flowers
bloom on the top and they go for the
town everything oh I think I think part
of the problem too is we just got back
from seeing a really bad movie at the
cinema and we're still decompressing
this yeah we can't say what it is yet
but maybe yeah maybe it'll I don't know
it's like damn and needing the
creativity imagination but yeah it kind
of sucked the life out of me for at
least a few minutes so we'll see if we
can get a groove going with the next
episode I will say yeah I can't think of
much to say I will say dogcopter three
with a moving on what I saw earlier so
um with uh I'll say there is something
that they do I'm seeing more more on
shows which I like a kind of about peer
pressure in stuff Malkin they'll did
best but I like shows I kind of show
like cuz it's are just beautiful for
whatever and it's Kelly yeah just get
your ass kicked
hey it's like to point B yourself but at
the same time they also show if you try
too hard to impress and you try like to
be kind of yes-man and everything like
that doesn't always work either you know
you guys kind of just own it there's a
nice in-between yeah somewhere is in
between sometimes being yourself can be
a little too much ya know there's a
definite there's definitely people where
I'm like can you be a little less you I
know you're a good person deep down but
could you be a little less you right now
you know we come across people like that
or it's like I'm just I'm not gonna have
any filter at all it's gonna be 100
percent me whatever and it's like I
wasn't gonna go that far all I was
saying is that part of socializing is
sometimes you need to know the right
places to be yourself and sometimes you
need to be like humble
more reserved guarded because otherwise
I'm gonna get into troubles no that's
what I'm saying and they're okay it just
sounded like you were know like don't
ever be you okay whoever you are let me
say that you're you yeah it's very
tender to hear with your family
uh no but there are times where it's
like you sort of need like there's
there's kind of manners and environments
and politeness that you know you should
sort of figure out like get a groove for
instance and honest I just cannot be
certain oh just jerks
some people are dicks and I'm like those
people don't be yourself yeah pretend to
be the nice guy for a few minutes please
what are those people that like never
get attention when they finally get they
want soak up as much as they can and
then they go too far and stuff like that
I mean it's like there's yeah we
actually know them my how to navigate
yeah so being yourself is fine just know
how to use it with great with great
power and there's no greater power than
being yourself comes great
responsibility
this thought you to that honestly uh you
know it's like that is kind of the
ultimate power is yourself that's the
ultimate power but there is a
responsibility to it as well and there's
an in-between somewhere um you know
there's other people you can totally be
yourself to and they'll trust and and
those people are wonderful these are
people where you kind of know like okay
I can't Foley and I shouldn't fully be
myself around this person like through
says some people are consummate
gossipers yeah they should there's no
you see themselves because there's some
people who shouldn't know certain things
so yeah yeah and there's people that's
like it but there's still good qualities
about them and you want to be their
friend and stuff but it's like okay I
know not to tell this to you you know or
it's just one of those things are there
certain things you know you can give and
reveal to people there's other things
that you shouldn't ah
and yeah I think especially now with the
social media I know for yourself but
make sure it's your best self but you
know I'm talking about that especially
with the social media like people want
to share everything and people you know
can use that to their advantage and they
can use it to hurt you and stuff and
there's some people who yawn like these
racist crazy rants like one is do myself
it's free speech it's like yeah but
they're just saying they don't like you
when you're being yourself yeah is what
it is so if there's anything to take
from this and the
episode never be yourself it's a
terrible idea just lie all the way
through but no madam that's and owning
that you are an awful therapist no but
that's what this episode is showing it
slowly if you try the lie you try to
blend in and nod oh you know be yourself
it's just gonna be attacked on the soup
are ya then which item which is what I
enjoy because it made her what he said
it was always the wrong guy always the
opportune stop trying
so um yeah I mean I like you fine and I
guess it's I do like that they do it a
little better here because like I said I
think in the after-school specials that
we watch it's always like just always be
yourself and it's like yeah that's a
good message but if I know there's a way
to like you said sir to a half and a
half and you need to know when to show
all of yourself and when to click little
bit more bizarre I think they got it
okay so uh but yeah there it is that's
about all we can get out of this one and
I'm just waiting for the big reveal that
those are the gems kids Wow now that
would be interesting
hi just why would they look like them I
I don't get why they would design them
that way you know cancer cell I'm just
now the 611 microcosm and the kid who
was trying to get in with them he's
obviously Steven so it's just a bizarro
universe version maybe everybody has
their doppelganger maybe and some are
just the opposite gender as well so yeah
I'm wonder if they have air explain that
why are they ever explain why they look
like that but maybe not maybe it's just
like round designs just throw something
teach you have a really fast which will
probably get all these rise oh dude you
have no idea you'll have no idea they
are actually in the county fairs wait
why most innocuous things we have talked
about sometimes like I will get a
response like that no clue dude yeah you
think we're seeing like and it's
always the things at least display would
be like like watch it'll be like Oh Doug
dogcopter man topic on say today
no they're humid venture you are going
to your pants it's adventure time
there is literally a tiny snail in the
background of every episo-- like
sometimes just for like a second or
something like that and later I becomes
like a huge character so it's like
sometimes they just do that ah so
it could be I don't sing you like dog
copter now but you're gonna piss
yourself in fear 20 episodes now that's
all I got I I think dogcopter speaks for
itself
woof woof